las áreas es el sistema legal del islam
literalmente significa el camino actúa
como un código de vida al que se deben
adherir los musulmanes en algunos países
funciona como una constitución pero
existen diversas posiciones de sobre
cómo se debe aplicar la sharia desde
posturas más flexibles hasta
interpretaciones rigurosas que incluyen
castigos físicos como amputaciones y
latigazos el grupo talibán se
caracteriza por su interpretación
fundamentalista que afecta sin
discriminación a la población civil que
vive bajo su yugo especialmente a las
mujeres y colectivos lgtb y más puesto
que implica para las mujeres no poder
moverse de manera libre sin el
acompañamiento de un varón la obligación
de cubrirse completamente con un velo no
poder casarse con un hombre no musulmán
ni divorciarse sin la aprobación de su
marido
los talibán ha reprimido a las mujeres
durante años así que como pueden darles
derechos cuando piensan que las mujeres
deben quedarse en casa que no pueden
salir a pedir un balón a dan adoraba
están tan bien prohibidas las relaciones
homosexuales o identificarse con un
género que no esté reconocido por el
corán sin embargo los insurgentes
anunciaron que iban a garantizar el buen
vivir de los ciudadanos
ahora es el momento de evaluar y probar
tenemos que mostrar y tratar de
averiguar cómo podemos servir a nuestra
nación y garantizar la seguridad la
calidad de vida y la satisfacción de una
vida pacífica en el futuro richmond
sacamos cabales o una declaración que no
convence a varios defensores de los
derechos humanos